I know it puts things into perspective
for me Julie Chrisley seemingly in
denial about her prison sentence we all
think our heart is the hardest thing on
the latest episode of Chrisley
confessions Julie's joined by her son
Chase's fiancee Emmy meters and the
reality star who's set to report to
prison this month with her husband Todd
reflects on having to spend years apart
from him there is that possibility of my
husband and I being separated
but there's a difference between my
husband and I being separated
for a period of time and having to say
goodbye forever the difference she's
referencing how seeing Emmy's mother
care for her father during his ALS
diagnosis put things into perspective so
it almost makes me feel
ashamed that I'm even worried you know
she's going to have to say goodbye to
her husband
[Music]
and she won't see him again this side of
Heaven
[Music]
and so I think it puts things into
perspective I made that commitment that
no matter how tough things were I was
not going to walk away and you know as
our marriage perfect no it's not but I
do think we have this mutual respect and
we both agree that we're not throwing in
the towel no matter how tough things get
and you know from a blended family to
having our own kids to just all the
drama that comes along with life it's
easy to do after being convicted of tax
fraud in June Julie sentenced to seven
years in prison and 16 months probation
while Todd sentenced to 12 years in
prison and 16 months probation I would
love to say it's all scripted but you
can't script the dysfunction that goes
on and on there's nothing else for you
to know about us it's all out there so
there's no bombshells according to docs
obtained by ET the couple's been ordered
to report to two different federal
prisons on January 17th what we will not
do is we will not break we made a
commitment that we were not going to
give up in the podcast Julie also gets
emotional when mentioning the moments
she'll miss having with her kids it's
like you know Grace and you know asking
me to you know
make him something or Chloe asking for
an ice cream cone something as simple as
that but the idea of me not being able
to do that breaks my heart and
unfortunately we have to hit those
places sometimes before we realize all
the blessings that we have but despite
enduring the separation Julie says she
thinks the family will grow closer from
it all no matter what no matter what the
future looks like I feel like that our
family will continue to strengthen
absolutely and we will love on a
different level even yeah
and that's that gives me hope
[Music]